hi I'm Erik Bosse and Avengers end game
re-released this weekend loving us 3000
by kicking avatar off the top spot
because love is a zero-sum game in
addition to a post credit deleted scene
featuring an n64 graphics Hulk which I
broke down in another video Marvel
released an exclusive sneak peek at
spider-man far from home I'm gonna
quickly break that down for you and for
the morning because I guess people yell
at me when I don't say that oh well here
we go okay so after the Hulk deleted
scene text shows and one more thing and
then we see a religious statue in the
Mexican desert a car pulls up to the
ruins of the town of extinct oh Mexico
Maria hill in Nick Fury exit the car
with Hill saying Nick this was a tragedy
but it's not why we're here
what are we fighting the winner man fury
responds the locals said the cyclone had
a face people see things when they're
under stress hill reasons but then
Mysterio Clinton backdrops in and a puff
of green smoke he asks who are you and
then behind Furion Hill a big sand
monster arises roaring they fire at it
Beck says you don't want any part of
this then fires as green energy blasts
and scene so we have seen some of this
scene in trailers but this looks like
the introduction of Mysterio to fury in
he'll early and far from home and we
learned that these element based
monsters terrorizing earth which I have
theorized could be false-flag
puppeteered projections by Beck himself
some of them begin their warpath in
Central America before destroying
European landmarks now the license plate
on the car beside Furion hill includes
the numbers 4 6 3 which is likely a
reference to the comic the amazing
spider-man number 4 which came out in
1963 and was the introduction of the
villains Sandman Flint Marko
but Maria Hills lying about mass
hysteria delusion is interesting could
also help explain why Mysterio would be
so successful with his illusions if that
ends up being true half the world
remember is still dust and stuff off
literally from returning after a
five-year time jump when the Avengers
were able to restock them back into
existence in defeat Thanos and ingame so
everyone is still shaken on this world
they're less skeptical and they're
definitely more susceptible to the kind
of theatrics that Mysterio may be
peddling now again go check out my other
video for my breakdown of the end
deleted scene that played after the
credits of the re-release featuring a
pre CGI rendered hulk a lot of
interesting stuff there and comment down
below with your thoughts on this follow
me on instagram and twitter at EA ba
subscribing the rocks or breakdowns of
theories of everything Marvel related
thanks for joining me bye bye
[Music]